which located all the stationary points
with discern their nature okay so now we
get to do the fun bit
hence graph now in year nine
you could have graphed this already okay
but what this is providing is a lot of
extra information for what it's going to
look like and we can be precise okay so
if we graph something go back to United
of you what could you do this to make it
easier to graph your factorize right so
you can take out the X that'll leave you
with x squared minus one and of course
you can factorize that as well right so
that's difference of squares okay so
this thing's gonna have three Brits
which is not unusual for a cubic at
zeroed one at minus one okay or in order
-1 0 and 1 okay now you sort of already
know what this is going to look like
okay but before you do it let's think
about what part they told us okay now we
know in these stationary points are and
this always bugged me before when I was
graphing with things like a cubic ok do
you know even in year 10 ok people would
ask well you know like a point like that
okay where is that and the most
immediate sort of instinctive response
is well if this is minus 1 and this is 0
you would expect it to me like halfway
between right and negative 1/2 that's
the way parabolas work you want to find
the vertex
it's just halfway between the roots ok
but as you can see or look at these
values maybe they're the best you can
see they're not symmetrical it's not a
point 5 it's just a bit off so minus
0.58 if you um now this is where you'll
be careful for scale right if you put
this distance here this is minus 1 this
is 0 okay you're stationary point is
about minus 0.6 right so it's closer to
this side it shouldn't be halfway ok so
I'm guessing that's sort of halfway
does that look about right so I want a
bit to the left okay so I actually want
it to be something like that ok now
that's a stationary point so to help me
draw it I'm gonna put a horizontal line
there okay because the gradient at that
point should be 0
that make sense well okay if this is the
question I suppose strictness would come
down to how many marks this was on
differences like hate or station points
determine their nature this would be
probably three months okay half a bar to
find each stationary point and then
assume abstraction to tell you in the
nature because that's that's a fair bit
of work here when you're getting to the
graph it's sort of up for debate how
many marks you put on that so if for
instance I saw say three marks it's
quite a lot for a graph especially being
that you've done all this legwork before
that you don't need to do again okay so
for this I'll expect your scale you know
and also it says showing your features
so in a second I'm gonna put I'm gonna
label these station points on there and
I'm gonna say that's point five eight
not point five so therefore yeah
especially when it says that just like
if we said pretty intercepts on you'd
want one and two and three to be evenly
spaced then you won't want them off all
right so let's keep going here's my max
turn you point in fact I might even
write that there max okay and you can
see from our our dashes here that I can
sort of expect it's gonna do this okay
so there's one side right that's what's
in that we'll see we'll see how my
second half goes now it's an odd
function okay so I should get the mirror
image on the right-hand side except sort
of rotated so again I'm going to want my
minimum turning point to not be position
halfway between 0 and 1 but a bit to the
right
it's point five eight right so okay so
again I think a really helpful thing to
make sure your curvature is good because
that would be you know half of one of
the marks would be on how neat it is you
put that horizontal line there so that
when you're done it really will be a
stationary point it won't be like all
those bouncy things okay it's got to
come to a nice neat smooth curve all
right so
finish yourself that's okay
I think there's a minimum
ah done now we probably should since it
says graphic show all features we've
already put the intercepts on and you
know you guys know it's important to
label intercepts so now that you know
how to talk about turning points we also
ought to label those as well sorry that
they turned out to be such terrible
coordinates but I thought I'd pick a
nice simple function so let's put them
on
tada okay yeah okay the photographic
like partially to that point and she
really didn't like okay uh so so this is
just a practical question do you do it
by bits or do you just go one smooth
curve you do need to have as what you
present it needs to be one smooth Joe
okay now here I can sort of get away
with it because I sort of does look like
if it was not that I'm probably slower
you could see I couldn't get one line
through there right
however what you want to avoid I think
we've talked about it is yeah well
you've got like let's say two lines but
like 50 okay so you want to avoid
something like oh I sort of want to get
like a smooth sort of okay so a lot of
people the graphs look like that I know
I have a ton graphs like that and you
like you know this is this is no good
because like if you add you know a
couple more legs and you're like you
know you've got like a head PR you like
I'm a cowboy okay so don't do that
because yeah yeah you're drawing you're
doing a curve not not malleable okay so
what I would do is if you if you
absolutely can't and you know let's face
it it's actually quite hard to get the
curvature really nice first go okay
here's what I would do I draw my camel
but I draw it in pencil okay really
really light pencil okay and then I've
got this is dangerous to say but either
in pen or in a much hotter pencil right
put one smooth curve through it so you
do your fairy thing first right and
that's sort of sort of like okay there's
my general shape okay and then you put
your line through it now once you put
that line through if you've done it hot
enough in pencil or a pen you can just
wipe off all the firm okay so you do
need to present one speed curve